let's back up for a minute Paul so that
we all understand this this would be a
Chinese version of Saturday Night Live
so not the same actors we're used to
seeing every Saturday night no this
would be local content local actors
local comedians local writers so it
would really be and obviously in Chinese
so but you know trying to bring some of
the sensibilities and you know comedy
success strategies that have been so you
know tried and true for many years over
SNL bring them to China which obviously
is a large market and then one in which
a lot of the media companies / / years
I've had a hard time cracking so what
we've seen from a lot of really your
company so before before we get into all
of that does it does it culturally
translate I mean why not just create a
comedy show a variety comedy show of
sorts online why do you have to team up
and specifically bring in SNL what is it
that Lorne Michaels brings to the table
well believer not sketch comedy actually
actually fares very well in China so
it's a it's a form of comedy that does
very well on television so I think you
know all that you know so who was trying
to do is they're trying to capitalize on
you know the brand that SNL has which
obviously is not as big in China as it
is in the United States I guess my
question I mean it does it translate
does the brand really matter in China
the way it would here in the US and and
and that's one of the big issues that
yeah yeah so they they have been
streaming the US show into China wit
Chinese sub subtitles for years so there
is some awareness of the product in the
marketplace but I think they're simply
looking for you know some of the
expertise that Lorne Michaels a
production company does in terms of live
television or sketch comedy and that's
something that they can bring to the
table so what we're seeing is a lot of
partnerships party does NBC get any
anything out of this no I don't think
they do I think this is a deal strictly
between Lorne Michaels production
company and so who